hey guys welcome back to another monday
morning review with his side of spoilers
I'm Zach hi Mary L and we're here to
review 22 Jump Street the sequel to 21
Jump Street and my favorite movie of the
year really well maybe not my favorite
but the funniest movie of the year it
was pretty funny I mean I saw neighbors
recently and I think that this was
better this was exactly what it promised
it was a sequel I mean it's it's phillip
lord and chris miller and they've
directed now lego movie this year 21
Jump Street beer before or two years
before they had cloudy with a chance of
meatballs there from How I Met Your
Mother days and I mean they're just on
fire so this time they're heading to
college and they're out to find this new
drug called Wi-Fi which is work hard yes
to play hard yes and I guess its a mix
between an ecstasy and an adderall and
they're out to find the drug dealer on
campus and that leads to Channing Tatum
actually reversing the role how Jonah
Hill was really popular when they went
back to high school and 21 Jump Street
Channing Tatum genco is now the man he's
on the the star wide receiver on the
football team he is just totally in his
element he's like the football star and
then you find out that Jonah
kind of like he doesn't have his friend
crew yeah and he's just really miserable
so like the whole story as it evolves
you kind of see you like them struggling
as friends and like how you know their
relationships kind of being tested so
what do you think is this better than 21
Jump Street oh definitely I think that
you know you kind of have to see 21 Jump
Street to appreciate you 22 yeah um but
it's just they really go for it and it's
a very we were talking it's like a
self-aware sequel you they play they
make fun of himself so what was your
favorite part of the movie um I actually
loved the credits I know it's funny
until I you know like the credits the
best but they were really funny but yeah
I mean they did so for those of you who
haven't seen it at in the credits
section they go on they do little mini
trailers for sequels to each movie they
start off with 23 Jump Street and I
think they go to maybe med school and
then it's like 24 Jump Street seminary
school 25 Jump Street I you know they go
into like where they go overseas it's
like a semester at sea yeah and then
they end up going up like like 32 or 33
drum Street generations and um there's
even a Jump Street where they replace
Jonah Hill Seth Rogen for one of the
trailers and it's one of the funnier
bits in the film and then the next very
next jump street he's back and they make
a joke out of it yeah there's a lot of
cameos yes
little time frame it's really funny well
I'm excited for 23 through 33 Jump
Street yeah I'm you too well for us here
at movieclips I'm Zach all right now
thanks for watching